des sprints et des sourires ce samedi 7
mai à vue en cours la ville a accueilli
la 8e édition des golden blog sur sa
place du marché le but réaliser une
course de 50 m en face à face sans
chrono un concept créé en 2014 par le
champion du monde d'athlétisme ladji
doucouré pour soutenir les quartiers
populaires en créer une espèce de
compétition qu'à rabat n'ont pas détecté
des enfants de huit à vingt ans
maintenant par catégorie d'âge et de
sexe et on essaie d'amener les meilleurs
de chaque quartier sur paris en fait on
essaie de faire en sorte que les
meilleurs de chaque quartier sa fronde
et devienne meilleure manière de la
france tout simplement cet événement est
une grande première sur le territoire
des yvelines séduit par le concept du
recours n'a pas hésité à organiser ce
rendez vous qui se rendra dans 28
communes de france dans les prochaines
semaines en général l'athlétisme on a
besoin de grands de grands équipements
des stades et gymnases pour courir
lancer sauter et là on vient tout à fait
au coeur des quartiers ici aujourd'hui
conduit routoirs au total plusieurs
centaines de jeunes ont pu s'essayer sur
ce 50 m
le maire possible portugal
on s'amuse rien
ne va on aura apprécié la course
d'ailleurs j'étais contre une fille et
moi j'ai mis toute ma force pour courir
parce qu'après la force est bien dans
tes pieds les grands gagnants de cette
journée se sont qualifiés pour la grande
finale nationale golden blocks un
événement programmé à l'automne